you are solving a system of two linear
equations in two variables you have
found more than one solution that
satisfies the system which of the
following statements is true but so
before even reading these statements
let's just think about what's going on
so let me draw my axes here let's draw
my axes so this is going to be my
vertical axis that could be one of the
variables and then this is my horizontal
variable my horizontal axis that's one
of the other variables and maybe for a
stake of convention this could be X and
this could be Y but they're whatever our
two variables are so it's a system of
two linear equations so if we're
graphing them each of the linear
equations in two variables can be
represented by a line now there's only
three scenarios here one scenario is
where the lines don't intersect at all
so the only way that you're going to
have two lines in two dimensions that
don't intersect is if they have the same
slope and they have different
y-intercepts so that's one scenario but
that's not the scenario that's being
described here they say you have found
more than one solution that satisfies
the system here there are no solutions
so that's not the scenario that we're
talking about there's another scenario
where they intersect in exactly one
place so they intersect in exactly one
place there's one point one X y
coordinate right over there that
satisfies both of these constraints but
this also is not the scenario they're
talking about there's there's they're
telling us that you have found more than
one solution that satisfies the system
so this isn't the scenario either so the
only other scenario that we can have we
don't have parallel lines that don't
intersect we don't have lines that only
intersect in one place the only other
scenario is that we're dealing with the
situation where both linear equations
are essentially the same constraint
they both are essentially representing
the same XY relationship that's the only
way that I can have two lines and this
is only this only applies to linear
relationship and lines but the only way
that two lines can intersect more than
one place more than one place is if they
intersect everywhere so in this
situation we know that we must have an
infinite number of solutions so which of
these choices say that this one right
here there are infinitely many more
solutions to the system right over there